it's a risky business inviting boris
johnson to your party conference
the former foreign secretary has a habit
of stealing the show
good afternoon
thank you so much good afternoon good
afternoon my fellow
my fellow unionists
[Applause]
he couldn't have wished for a more
receptive audience so didn't hold back
in passing judgment on the draft
withdrawal agreement
we are on the verge of making we are on
the verge of making
a historic mistake and i just say this
unless we change course we are going to
stay
in the customs union we're going to stay
in the single market
we're going to be rules takers and
unless we junk this
backstop we're going to find that
brussels
has got us exactly where they want us
[Applause]
under pressure to deliver the speech of
her political life arlene foster
acknowledged the public finance
scandal that had brought down northern
ireland's devoted government
today as leader of this party i
apologize
but it didn't take her long to get back
to brexit
the choice is not between this deal and
no deal
despite what the government spin machine
may say
the reality is that if we are to secure
a better outcome
than is currently on offer then the only
option
is to look beyond the current draft
withdrawal agreement
and work in the time ahead for an
improved outcome
there's no denying their allegiance they
don't come more british
but conference delegates have lost trust
in the british prime minister
i'm disappointed in the prime minister
and i know many many people
have spoken to over this last week are
equally so
we are very much telling her that she
needs to bend the backstop
or uh she will face problems in the
future
she's the british prime minister or part
of the uk we're british
you want you want to accept the word of
the british prime minister but when she
lets you down then that makes you
worried
this was a much more conciliatory speech
than anticipated
an indication perhaps that the dup are
keen to rebuild the devoted government
here in northern ireland
and to avoid the collapse of the
minority government of westminster
by securing a new brexit deal
that's easier said than done but when
you're holding the balance of power
you don't relinquish it lightly david
blevins
sky news in belfast